hello everyone Welcome to Our advice
show what should I drew it's a new one
and we're getting to launch it with none
other than Nicole Richie
now
I wanted to ask you questions
um on fashion because you are a fashion
icon so are you ready I am ready this is
also questions that people sent in Via
social media what should I wear on a
first date oh okay I'm gonna go with
what my husband would say because I
think girls and guys do expect different
things I have heard across the table
that guys actually prefer when you do
less they that they don't like a lot of
makeup and accessories that they like
want to see what a woman really looks
like that's what I heard I don't know if
it's true but I'm that is what I'm
hearing just repeating what I feel so
Vindicated right now is 80s style making
a comeback and if so what should I get
to participate in it 80s style yeah I
don't think 80s ever goes out of style
yeah I mean I don't know I personally I
think that the 80s get a bad rap and I
think that's like actually one of the
most like I think it's such a Chic
decade the big eyebrows like shoulder
pads shoulder pads like I'm actually
very into it I don't know I mean
what you could do to bring back 80s
style I think shoulder pads a narrow
waist I was watching baby boom the other
night ooh love Baby Boom yes yes
the epitome of 80s style Diane Keaton
sheer tights I think that would be a
good place to start I never wear tight
but don't oh my God you live in New York
you never wear I never wear tights
they're very tight in the cross I would
have to do singular legs yes which is
very sexy by the way maybe you should do
that tomorrow while you do this show
okay a little
well is that right is that your advice
yes that is my advice all right for
Nicole's advice I am going to wear
Hosiery yes a viewer wrote in can I wear
Crocs oh
yeah sure wear whatever you want here's
my advice we're whatever the hell you
want wear what makes you feel
comfortable all right completely agree
by the way props are so cool now they're
all the cool kids are wearing it I like
a Croc and sock okay I love a Croc and
sock What accessories work with casual
clothes like I do wear a lot of sweat
pants and t-shirts can I accessorize
with that with the sweatpants yeah
um I wouldn't I mean maybe no no you
can't but if it's jeans and a t-shirt
yeah I mean I actually play with
accessories way more sometimes I'll wear
the same thing just over and over and
then just accessorize differently so I'm
all about like changing up the jewelry
changing up the shoe the bag like
there's actually a lot that you can do
with wearing like a and be a you know
Levi's and white T-shirt type of type of
gal can you wait in the in on the war
against skinny jeans what is the War I
don't even know I wear them so I I don't
I don't am I winning or losing in this
world I don't know okay I don't know
after two kids jeans are not for me
anymore
Nicole thank you for that Sage advice
and I'm going to take a photo and text
it to you of me and my Hosier yes so I'm
excited I'm looking forward to it yeah
I'm showing don't forget to tune in to
Comedy Central to watch Nicole's new
movie cursed friends in October and
making the cut is now on Prime video if
you have questions for us to answer drop
them in the comments below and make sure
to subscribe to our channel for more
we'll see you later